es un gusto estar para mí con todos
ustedes
si sabían que el 74 por ciento de las
personas hacen algo que no les gusta
esto según la revista expansión y algo
que todavía se me hace más más
interesante es que 3 de cada 10 personas
que emprenden lo hacen por una necesidad
mientras que el otro 777 personas lo
hacen por una necesidad porque me llamo
el tema de echando a emprender se
aprende díganme quién de aquí levante la
mano le da miedo
no sé cometer un error
entonces aquí en nosotros yo creo que la
gran mayoría no alcanzo a ver muy bien
pero creo que toda la levantaron
yo recuerdo que cuando era chico algo
que yo siempre tenía como un estigma es
que cuando cometes un error eres un
perdedor no si fracasa tus negocios ya
ves te habíamos dicho para que renuncias
a tu trabajo si estabas bien como te vas
a dedicar a este tema del negocio
echando emprender son una serie de pasos
que te voy a compartir el día de hoy
quiero empezar con esta historia en una
ocasión iba a un mentor con su alumno
iban caminando en un pueblo y de repente
el mentor de en el monte una vaca al
lado de una casa humilde y le dice a su
alumno desbarranca esa vaca y el alumno
se queda así pero
a medio loco mi mentor o que como que
desbarranca la vaca no se desbarrancan
entonces el alumno no entendiendo muy
bien porque le estaba diciendo esto el
mentor pues va a ir desbarranca la vaca
así como lo estamos viendo en la imagen
con el transcurso de los años el alumno
se quedó como pensativo y se quedó con
el remordimiento porque asumía que las
personas que vivían en esa casa es
obviamente vivían de la vaca no el pensó
por lógica por sentido común esto y
pasaron los años y el alumno se
convirtió en maestro y al destino la
casualidad como lo quieran llamar y el
alumno vuelve ir a este pueblo entonces
con la pena y todo eso del val velada el
mentor y de una casa hermosa en el monte
se queda caray son de haber cambiado
quizá que les haber pasado los que
vivían ahí pero va a tocar la puerta le
abren oiga disculpara tengo una
curiosidad qué pasó con las personas que
vivían en esta casa no somos nosotros se
quedó sorprendido como inti intrigado no
hace se le ofrecemos un vaso de agua se
entra y mientras que está así como que
sacado de onda y le estaban diciendo el
tema de que ellos eran las personas que
vivían en esa casa dice ti que ese joven
y hace algunos años tuvimos una
desgracia se desgarran con la vaca y
pues nos quedamos sin comer y sin nada
nos estamos en una en un dilema de cómo
íbamos a sobrevivir entonces con esta
situación pues mi cuñado que ves ahí es
mi hermano me dijo que nos iba a poner a
pintar yo me hice carpintero y mi esposa
pues va a vender al mercado o frutas y
lejos de haber sido una desgracia que
cree que fue lo que pasó fue todo lo
contrario ahora entonces con esta
historia que les acabo de introducir
denomina el mapa del emprendedor porque
porque un emprendedor para mí es como un
explorador como un viajero constante no
sé si se identifiquen con eso pero yo
desde que decidí emprender siempre yo mi
mochila a todas partes y es como que
nueva experiencia voy a vivir el día de
hoy y nombre estos cinco puntos que no
nada más he visto en mí si no lo he
visto en grandes líderes que vamos a ver
a continuación con el punto número uno
el reto y lo hemos visto en otras de las
historias que han estado escuchando
-entre el punto número dos debes de
tener un equipo el punto número tres la
preparación el punto número cuatro viene
el desafío que implica cuando ya tienes
estos tres puntos anteriores y el último
viene una retroalimentación
a esto
y ponerles estos ejemplos bien de aquí
ubica a lorena ramírez durante la mano
de una corredora de fondo que fue muy
reconocida en el 2017 cuando ganó una
carrera de 50 kilómetros en 7 horas pero
lo más sorprendente de la arena que ya
tiene un documental en netflix hablando
de el documento de la plataforma que
hace unos momentos nos compartían ella
corre con huaraches 10 de los chistoso
en una de sus entrevistas decía bueno lo
chistoso para qué uso tenis ahí tenía
una caja de tenis que le regalaban si
los que 30 años vienen atrás de mí
entonces fíjense cómo es este tema no el
dilema de decir oye pues es que yo
necesito un robert me estás diciendo que
el paso número 2 son el equipo lo que yo
necesito sí pero en muchas ocasiones
vamos a hablar de otro tema más adelante
que tiene que ver con el main set pero
cada uno de estos emprendedores como
oprah winfrey el olmos y walt disney
enfrentaron un desafío específico en el
caso de oprah fue usada cuando era joven
cuando era niña al punto de que algo que
le reconoce la gran comunidad porque es
una comunidad
de las mejores comunicadores que hay en
a nivel
es que haya sobresalido de esa situación
difícil en el caso del olmos el fundo
paypal junto con otro otro de sus
inversionistas amigo del act es la hace
spacex y se queda casi sin dinero y él
estaba en un dilema de si seguía o no
con su emprendimiento y que vimos en
febrero del 2018 cuando saca este tesla
roadster con el balcón al espacio y
todos somos sorprendidos por la magia de
ese gran evento que pasa con walt disney
uno de los mejores creativos que han
pasado a la historia de los años 20 y
que él fue despedido de un periódico
porque no tenía creatividad
el primer punto en el mapa del
emprendedor y esto lo pueden aplicar con
su pareja lo pueden aplicar en su
trabajo lo pueden aplicar en cualquier
negocio por eso me encanta este concepto
en una ocasión iba platicando con una
financiera y le empezó a platicar los
puntos inicio y robert si la gente
hiciera esos puntos para ahorrar sería
otra cosa del país para cualquier cosa
que podamos ver cualquier necesidad
estos puntos para mí son muy importantes
porque el primero es que yo es lo que
necesito hacer para que las cosas
sucedan un emprendedor que hace tiene
una idea pero que que más hace la
ejecuta la pone en acción entonces lo
primero que yo necesito si voy a poner
un ejemplo
un lugar de tacos es bueno necesito el
carrito necesito a lo mejor el permiso
necesito a lo mejor también conocer algo
de comida no serán como los aspectos
básicos que necesito yo si quiero
cambiar de trabajo y mi desafío es que
en donde están no me valoran soy del 74
por ciento de las personas que estoy
inconforme con lo que me dan por lo que
me pagan no me tratan bien entonces ese
es el primer punto que yo necesito saber
y es que es lo que necesito el segundo
punto la preparación si bien estamos
viendo la corredora mexicana a lo mejor
ella en lo que lleva la leña en donde
ella vive ida y vuelta son 8 horas y ese
es el entrenamiento que ella hace para
correr estos maratones de 100 horas de
100 kilómetros en 7 horas
entonces la preparación para mí es
importante porque no nada más es un tema
de decir bueno ya tengo el equipo ya
tengo el carrito robert ya tenia hace
algo de carnita ya sea como hacer los
preparativos ya tengo a mis a mis
posibles proveedores pero ahora lo que
necesito hacer que es prepararme no voy
a tomar un curso de cocina voy a ver de
qué manera me voy a diferencia
en el mercado del a lo mejor de don chuy
que está en la otra esquina de doña
paquita que está ahí al otro lado de la
cuadra entonces la preparación es
fundamental dado que ya tengo un reto y
algo que les quiero decir hace algún
tiempo platicando con un empresario me
decía cuál es la diferencia entre carlos
slim y la señora que tiene una tienda en
la esquina pues imaginan ustedes que es
esa gran diferencia
carlos slim- tenía claro lo que quería
hacer en qué nivel quería llegar ya lo
mejor la del señor de los tacos lo único
que quiere es tener su propio local pero
carlos slim o el hizo un emporio hizo
una empresa que está a nivel global no
tiene diferentes empresas
entonces la preparación y el reto es
fundamental para hacer
esto que se denomina el main set he
escuchado hablar mucho en foros
empresariales el mainz edelman se cambia
de mentalidad y que el mainz & los
cuchillos es el maicero entonces
investigando en este tema de decir bueno
15 el famoso mind sé que todo el mundo
está hablando los empresarios y los
emprendedores y que cambia tu mentalidad
y es algo que yo veo muy recurrentemente
cuando me muevo en una plataforma muy
reconocida que se llama über y habló con
uno de los suben y cómo te va el día
pues está todo podido la situación del
país y que no se empieza a platicar todo
lo malo que tiene en su vida no dice más
en chistoso porque algo que he aprendido
yo en este proceso de emprender es cómo
cambias el chip ante las situaciones
difíciles que tienes en la vida en
alguna ocasión leí un libro que se lo
recomiendo mucho deben de hallar un
psicólogo muy conocido en eeuu que se
llama tus zonas erróneas y él en una
ocasión estaban como en estas mesas que
están todos ustedes estaba un mesero de
repente atendiendo y empieza a gritar
esté tranquilo joven le va a dar un paro
cardíaco y es más no va a llegar a los
50 años ja ja ja se empieza a reír no
tiene razón tengo 50 años y el año
pasado me dio un paro cardíaco de joven
lo que le estoy diciendo entonces
continúa escribiendo y dice que las
pensamos que donde nacemos que lo que
nos han enseñado así vamos a hacer para
toda la vida
levante la mano quien piensa eso es que
mi mamá era desorganizada que llegó a
hacernos organizado es que pues mi
familia no es emprendedora y yo no yo no
voy a ser emprendedor porque les digo
esto porque wind ayer hace esta
reflexión y dice
tú puedes cambiar tu realidad siempre y
cuando aprendas eso que tú no tienes de
otra persona que sí lo tienen yo debo de
reconocer que está bien desorganizado
levante la mano aquí quien es
desorganizado que no les dé pena no
levanten la mano viejo que van a decir
de nosotros entonces
cuando cuando yo veo esto yo veía mi
escritorio como buen ingeniero un
desmadre no hay papeles y le decía mi
esposa no no no no me muevas eso que ya
abajo de eso está el recibo de tal cosa
pero no no no no hay soy un genio más
bien un genio que más que genio
siguiendo esto veo que el no tener orden
en mi vida me quita eficiencia entonces
al leer esto the wind ayer digo yo puedo
aplicar eso en mi vida entonces agarré a
una [ __ ] dow y agarra una lista risso
de listas y listas y más listas que son
un libro buenísimo y empiezo a poner
orden en mi vida entonces el tema del
mainz es más que algo que esté de moda y
todo eso es un tema de poner en práctica
y empezar a cambiar estas estas
creencias que tenemos de no lograr lo
que queremos el desafío el desafío es
cuando yo ya estoy en la misma prueba
que lo que pasa cuando tú ya tienes tu
puesto de tacos
o pues es que la paciencia porque el
cliente llegó y me aventó el taco y
luego que se quemó la carne y luego que
se nos echaron a perder las tortillas y
es un desafío no entonces el tema de
emprender este mapa de emprender no nada
más es decir puse el negocio es ok tengo
el negocio como lo voy a hacer crecer
como me voy a apalancar porque la gran
mayoría empieza con dinero propio
pero la gran mayoría que tienen aquí
levante la mano tiene un emprendimiento
ahora si le da pena toda nadie
hasta el mismo trabajo es un
emprendimiento entonces el desafío es
como yo le hago para que el reto que yo
tengo que debe de poner más atrás usar
las manos y sacarme de mi zona de
confort cuando yo ya estoy en el desafío
es cuando yo pongo ya en fracc ten en
experiencia en ese momento en vivo todas
estas cosas que yo he estado realizando
para que en ese momento cualquier
situación que se me presente yo pueda
vencerla
después en este análisis viene una
retroalimentación que ya tengo mi puesto
ya hace más o menos hacer los tacos ya
no se me quema la tortilla pero sé que
puedo mejorar los procesos si yo quiero
que mi negocio de changarrito pase a una
franquicia tengo que empezar a
sistematizar entonces esta
retroalimentación a mí lo que me da es
un feedback real de qué es lo que me
duele y qué es lo que puedo mejorar para
hacer cosas más extraordinarias en mi
vida
antes de pasar a esta última diapositiva
quiero comentarles una última historia
de un elefante iba una vez un papá lo
llevo al circo y estaba caminando y el
niño de repente en un elefante gigante
se han ido al circo bueno no sé si ahora
los circos ya no tienen animales pero
hace muchos años cuando te vas al circo
pues está a un elefante grandísimo con
una cadena agarrado a una estaca no y
llegó a ver eso
bueno no sé si ustedes llegaron a
cuestionar esto pero al niño muy
inteligentemente le decía oye papá
porque el elefante está amarrado esa
estaca de esa cadena y no se estafa si
es tan grande y poderoso y podría
derribar hasta un muro y todo eso no la
sé mira hijo es que hace algunos años
cuando ese elefante era chico es el
intento muchas veces afán se destaca que
estaba amarradas a esa cadena que los
que lo sostienen en el suelo pero
intentó una y otra vez y el elefante no
podía zafarse y obviamente le lastimada
porque poseer a un elefante chiquito
entonces el elefante pues obviamente al
estar lastimado seguía intentando seguir
intentando hasta que un día que entre
que creen que pasó el elefante dejó de
insistir hoy que es un elefante grande y
poderoso y que pudiendo quitarse esa
cadena de risa con un solo movimiento no
lo hace
cuántas estacas tienen ustedes hoy en su
vida
cuántas creencias tienen hoy en este
momento que no los limitan a realmente
llevar la magia que tiene cada uno de
ustedes por aportar al mundo todos
tienen un talento todos tienen un don y
el peor error que podemos hacer siempre
es compararnos con otras personas porque
todos tenemos algo que aportar a este
mundo ya este planeta entonces lo que te
quiero invitar el día de hoy sea que
reflexionemos que sepamos en este
proceso en este mapa del emprendedor las
cosas no siempre van a salir como
queremos
ya loco y lógico decir que siempre las
cosas vamos a ganar no en la vida en las
vidas a veces se gana ya veces se pierde
a veces vas a hacer algún negocio y te
va a funcionar y a veces va a ser es va
a ser ese negocio y no va a funcionar
cuando yo hablaba con este über que se
estaba quejando de la vida ya cerrando
la parte de esa historia yo le hablé de
un libro que para mí cambió mi forma de
pensar con respecto al dinero de los
secretos de la mente millonaria de heart
care él dice que la gente rica no le da
miedo invertir el dinero porque si lo
pierde lo puede volver a generar qué
pasa con la mentalidad pobre la
mentalidad pobre es tengo cinco pesos y
mejor los guardo en la bolsa o debajo
del colchón porque si no me lo va a
robar mi señora mi suegra o quién sabe
quién o los mejores lo guardo está
segurito y termino está perdiendo ese
dinero entonces cuando iba llegando con
el uvero a su casa que es en mi casa yo
le comenté una cosa te puedo decir que
el poder de la mente puede hacer que
generes todo aquello que quieras y se
los voy a dar con un rápido ejemplo qué
pasa cuando ustedes dicen me voy a caer
me voy a caer me voy a caer qué pasa
ustedes me van a chingar me van a ching
de pechina no ese es un [ __ ] pues va a
ser un [ __ ] veces ese no es confiable
ellos
lo dije no era confiable entonces
empiezo a hacer un prejuicio empiezas a
actuar programarte de que la gente es
mala y que la gente no cambia llevar la
magia es empezar el cambio desde adentro
hacia afuera desde nosotros como
emprendedor algo que ha aprendido es que
yo soy el responsable de las decisiones
y de las acciones que yo hago todo el
tiempo en mi vida y nadie más tiene la
culpa ni mi tía ni mi abuelita no es que
mi señora la que no me deje no me
impulsa no cree en mí en mi negocio
cuando tú eres el primero que debes de
creer en esa idea y en ese negocio
nombre roberto de cerrar y los veo allá
donde en el monte donde las vacas cerdos
barrancas naciente